SIGMUND FREUD CALLED IT MARK
STEYN IS THE BEST-SELLING
AUTHOR AND REALLY THE BEST
GUEST ON TV AND JOINS US
TONIGHT.
SO, HERE IS YET ANOTHER
EXAMPLE, MARK, OF THEM
ACCUSING YOU OF WHAT THEY
ARE DOING.
ARE THEY NOT AWARE THAT THEY
ARE DOING IT?
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
I THINK HILLARY CLINTON IS
TOTALLY UNAWARE WHEN SHE
SAYS THAT YOU KNOW, YOU RUN
THE BEST CAMPAIGN AND ALL
THE REST OF IT SHE IS
ACTUALLY CLUTCHING AT STRAWS
AS TO WHY THE INEVITABLE
CANDIDATE DID NOT WIN.
BUT, THIS IS REALLY THE FLIP
SIDE OF WHAT YOU WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT WITH MOLLIE
RIGHT NOW.
THESE TWO STORIES RUN IN
PARALLEL.
THE DEMOCRATS ESSENTIALLY
PROVIDE POLITICAL COVER FOR
ALL THESE FBI TYPES
MONKEYING AROUND,
WIRETAPPING AND SURVEYING
THE OPPOSITION BECAUSE IF
THE DEMOCRATS DIDN'T LEND IT
POLITICAL COVER, WE WOULD
ALSO SEE IT FOR WHAT IT
GILAD SHALIT
WHLAD SHALIT
WHATD SHALIT
WHAT ISHALIT
WHAT ITHALIT
WHAT IT ILIT
WHAT IT IS.T
WHAT IT IS.GOING ROGUE.
THE INVESTIGATION OF GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS AND CO PROVIDE
COVER FOR THE DEMOCRATS AS
TO WHY TRUMP'S REPUBLICAN
VICTORIES ARE NEVER
LEGITIMATE.
IN A SENSE THESE TWO THINGS
OPERATE ON TWIN TRACKS AND
SUPPORT EACH OTHER.
WHETHER YOU HAVE SOMEONE
LIKE STACEY ABRAMS ACTUALLY
SAYING WE DON'T NEED TO
CONCEDE ANYMORE BECAUSE THIS
ENTIRE SYSTEM IS OPPRESSIVE
AND OUT TO GET US.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE COMING
CLOSE, ACTUALLY, TO MAKING
POLITICS ENTIRELY
IMPOSSIBLE.
AND WHEN YOU DO THAT IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY LEAVE MUCH
ELSE EXCEPT CIVIL WAR.
BY DELEGITIMIZING THIS
PROCESS, THEY ARE ACTUALLY
PLAYING WITH MATCHES.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU SAY THAT
THE ELECTION IS ILLEGITIMATE
BECAUSE THE SYSTEM IS
ILLEGITIMATE BECAUSE THE
FOUNDING DOCUMENTS ARE YOU
WILL LEGITIMATE BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE WHO WROTE THEM ARE
RACIST.
AT A CERTAIN POINT AREN'T
YOU SAYING I DON'T NEED TO
PLAY BY YOUR RULES I WILL
SEIZE POWER WHEN I CAN?
>> STACEY ABRAMS' ARGUMENT
UNLESS I WIN THE ELECTION
WAS RIGGED.
AND HILLARY CLINTON, WHO IS
A FAR MORE SENIOR FIGURE
THAN STACEY ABRAMS ACTUALLY
CAME CLOSE TO SAYING THAT ON
STAGE IN LOS ANGELES BECAUSE
I DIDN'T WIN, THE SYSTEM
MUSTING RIGGED.
AND ACTUALLY WHEN YOU READ
THAT NANCY PELOSI THING, I
DON'T THINK TRUMP IS LIKE
THAT AT ALL.
I THINK IF TRUMP WERE TO
LOSE NARROWLY, HE WOULD
SOUND OFF ON TWITTER.
HE WOULD SAY THE PRESIDENCY
IS FOR LOSERS.
LIVING IN THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS SO DEGRADING AFTER YOU
HAVE LIVED IN TRUMP TOWER,
I'M GOING TO BUILD A
FABULOUS NEW TRUMP RESORT IN
KAZAKHSTAN, SCREW YOU ALL.
HE WOULD HAVE A BALL.
IF HE LOST HE WOULD HAVE A
BALL AND HE WOULD BE GONE.
BUT WHAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
DONE FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS,
IN PARTICULAR HILLARY
CLINTON, IT'S HILLARY
CLINTON'S REFUSAL TO LOSE
TIED TO WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT WITH ALL THESE
DEEP STATE GUYS GOING ROGUE,
IN ALLIANCE WITH FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
EAVESDROPPING, MONITORING,
TRYING TO ENTRAP AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THAT'S -- THESE TWO CRIMES
ARE ACTUALLY THE SAME CRIME
AND ONE HALF SUPPORTS THE
OTHER HALF.
>> Tucker: VERY SMART AS